[Music]
welcome everybody to low in crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber and thanks for joining
us legal teams we're in an Idaho
courtroom Friday tackling six motions in
the case of Brian coburger now police in
Moscow Idaho say that Brian coburger
entered a rented home near the
University of Idaho last November and
stabbed four college students to death
Kaylee Gonzalez Madison Mogan Zana
kernodle and Ethan Chapin all died from
their wounds coburger was a doctoral
student at nearby Washington State
University Police collected trash from
coburger's parents home in Pennsylvania
where he was spending Christmas break
and used a DNA sample to link him to the
sheath of a knife found in one of the
bedrooms the defense team want access to
all the profiles that were uploaded to a
DNA database that would give them the
names of other people who were potential
match and any unknown male profiles as
well the defense also requested any of
the communications about the testing and
information about any issues with the
lab that did the testing during Friday's
hearing the judge allowed the defense to
call witnesses including a criminal
defense attorney with a specialization
in DNA a preeminent expert and he
testified about the importance of DNA
and knowing how it was collected
that the minimum practice standard is
that the attorney must obtain discovery
of the scientific testing of an Evidence
sample
and that
particularly so in the capital case
particularly what we're talking about an
environmental sample of trace DNA it's
it's absolutely crucial to do that
Discovery because then that informs the
scope of the investigation the experts
to hire and what happens now also with
response to the respect to the forensic
genealogy it's important not to to
separate this out into all these
different components it is you have the
s p testing and then you also have the
development of these family trees
through database searching this is all
part of the same testing and experiment
they go nearly hand in hand and you
can't unravel them
they really have to be considered
together as a single core work of
different strands
and experiment because the attorney
needs to know
how these family trees have been
developed because we're talking now
about Trial issues and the government is
introducing the Str profile they have to
introduce statistics that explain the
significance of any Str Mac that the
government has identifying as Central to
its case and so the defense must
investigate ways to cross-examine
those statistics and that the Rarity of
that match that the government is
attaching great significance to it okay
let's talk about this I'm joined right
now by my legal analyst my co-host Brian
buckmeyer Terry Austin Brian I'll start
with you I don't think I've ever seen an
attorney call another attorney to the
stand to explain why evidence is so
important that that team needs access to
it but he is a specialist he is a
specialist in DNA do you think it was
wise to bring him and do you think It
ultimately is going to convince the
judge I would actually disagree with you
it's a little bit there because I would
say that I'm a specialist in DNA he at
one point was considered the National
Standard for excellence in forensic
litigation he he's forgotten more about
DNA than I will probably ever learn and
so to have him on because I remember
before this I was like why would you do
this I want to turn into explain what
another attorney can do but no he is
there he's that guy and so I think it
makes sense because for a lot of Courts
and I think you talked about this before
as well
um they don't see this level of DNA
analysis from a day-to-day perspective
so having that guy come in and explain
why it's so important what you need to
be able to properly cross-examine I
think really pains a good picture for
the judge so so I guess the argument
would be and I know you've said that you
think the prosecution should turn all of
this over to the defense I would assume
their argument would be that may
compromise some of the investigative
methods from investigators like the FBI
and maybe and maybe there's privacy
issues as well maybe the defense
shouldn't have access to everything what
do you think well I think this guy is
not only that guy I think what he said
makes sense this is evidence that could
be exculpatory evidence and it's
evidence that the defense has to have to
defend their client it may reveal some
information the prosecution doesn't want
to be revealed but the bottom line is if
this can help the defense what if it
turns out that there was a procedure
major that was done faulty and it turns
out that the defense could have gotten
an expert to talk about that and it's
hurting the defense team and while you
know obviously we do want for this to be
the right defendant and we do want for
this case to conclude if it is wrong we
ought to know that from the beginning
and I I think they should turn over what
they have real quick the fact that the
judge is allowing this to be heard seems
like he's open to it open to also you
don't have to give all the information
to everyone you can do what's called an
Eyes Only uh release so only the
attorneys see this information so they
could probably defend their client I
think the judge is going to allow the
defense to see it but that's my guess
but we have a lot more to talk about
with this so coming up on Long crime
daily We are continuing our legal
analysis of Brian coburger's motions
hearing as we inch closer to a possible
trial the defense recently claimed that
the grand jury proceedings were flawed
and now the prosecution is responding
their argument that the charges against
Brian coburger are sound that's next
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody we are continuing our Deep
dive into emotions hearing for Brian
coburger the man accused of brutally
stabbing four University of Idaho
students to death another argument
addressed in court on Friday was over
the grand jury indictment at the end of
July coburger's lawyers filed a motion
to dismiss that indictment saying the
jury was misled about the standard of
proof the defense attorneys say the jury
should have been instructed that they
needed proof Beyond a reasonable doubt
that Brian coburger was the killer in
order for him to go to trial now
traditionally grand juries have a much
lower standard of proof to push through
an indictment in a response filed this
week the state called that theory
jarring and said that the Idaho Supreme
Court has said in other cases that the
grand jury is used to determine probable
cause the defense also wanted to discuss
allegations of Juror bias juror
questionnaires that were missing some
information and some apparent violations
because of how jurors actually answered
some of the questions before being
selected to serve so Terry probably
because is the standard that we've
always known that's you heard what the
the prosecution fired back who's going
to win that argument oh I think it's
going to be probable cause I don't think
it's going to be the higher standard you
have grand juries in every state and you
know most of the states do use grand
jury processes under certain
circumstances and in all of those states
it is the fact that it's a lower
standard it's just to bring the charges
against the defendant to bring the
indictment and so I think that the
prosecution in this case is going to
basically you know it's going to be the
grand jury you know probable cause it's
not going to be Beyond meaning it's fine
it's going to go through it's fine it's
going to go through now the statute's
not written properly I think they need
to clarify so that's the question they
do when after this came out I looked at
it and apparently in Idaho there is not
like a clear consensus I thought that
this was going to be one response from
the prosecution be like what are you
talking about look at X Y and Z even in
their response months they're like
basically even if there's ambiguity here
it's the Supreme Court that holds I'm
shocked that it took this case for there
to be a spotlight on I mean there was
some discussion that about this before
but they've always gone the probable
cause right what do you would take away
from it so I think it's unfortunately
going to take us back to one year our
first year of law school yeah where a
statute says one thing but the courts
have always interpreted as something
else right and so it comes down to one
side wants to say the way the
legislature wrote the law and
legislators right we argue it says it's
the same standard by which you have to
get a conviction which we all know is
proven Reasonable Doubt but the Supreme
Court of Idaho has always said it is
something else and I think what it has
to happen is the legislature has to go
back and finally get these two sides to
stop squabbling like children and say
you know what guys we're going to put it
all in the same boat we're going to have
the statute reflect what the law says
because ultimately if this judge does
say yeah the statute is correct this
doesn't get appealed to whoever wrote
the statute right it gets appealed to
the Supreme Court of Idaho who's already
said this is the rule and there was
language like it would warrant a
conviction the prosecution was like that
means you could authorize it but doesn't
mean it's like two different standards
real quick you think the legislature is
going to change this now that this
became so high profile because they want
to make sure that everyone understands
what the standard is and obviously it's
not even logical to have a standard
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt because then
why would you even have a try I'll just
say this much I thought it was an
interesting legal argument from a lawyer
perspective I hadn't heard it before but
I think the prosecution is going to win
the day on that one all right